Billy Loomis was born in 1978 or 1979 as the
son of Henry Loomis and Nancy Loomis. Henry
was once a lawyer for the movie studio Sunrise
Studios, but in April 1974, after helping the
studio escape from a lawsuit regarding one
of their actresses going missing on set,
he left the Studio and moved up north -- to
Woodsboro, California, where he met Nancy.
Unfortunately, he could not leave his
scandalous Hollywood life in the rearview,
because after Billy was born, he had an
affair with a woman who also fled Sunrise
Studios for a quieter life in Woodboro. Her
name was Maureen Prescott. Little did he know,
Maureen was quite a tramp. She
had a secret-son named Roman,
who was secretly watching and video taping
their broad-daylight encounters in cheap motels.
When Billy’s mother found out about the
infidelity, she split up with Henry and
skipped town, leaving behind Billy with
his father. As Billy describes himself,
maternal abandonment causes serious deviant
behavior. However, he managed to keep a
respectable public persona and seems to be
fairly popular in school. He had developed
a love of movies, perhaps partially intrigued
by his Dad’s former career at Sunrise Studios,
and he has a group of friends
who share this passion with him.
Because of his obsession with cinema and
his inability to cope with abandonment,
he’s an easy target when he meets Roman sometime
in 1994, who was now an up and coming music video
director who similarly could not get over
being forgotten by his mom. He showed Billy
the footage of Maureen and Hank having the
affair, and even helped him plot his revenge.
Because Roman was a director, looking
to get into feature films in the future,
his ideas for Billy were very much
like something out of a movie:
such as having a partner to sell out in case
he got caught, and finding someone else to
frame for his crimes. Billy chose his easily
peer-pressured friend Stu Macher to be his
accomplice and decided to frame the subject
of Maureen’s newest affair, Cotton Weary.
But getting his revenge on Maureen was not enough,
he also wanted to hurt her daughter,
Sidney Prescott. Billy is considered an
attractive guy in the high school social
sphere. Tatum Riley calls him flawless…
– He was destined to have a
flaw. I knew he was too perfect.
–[Zac] ...and other girls at the school gossip about
his bubble butt. For these reasons, it’s not
hard for him to get Sidney to date him, and the
relationship started off hot and heavy. But that
would change when Billy’s plan went into action
in September 1995. One night, Billy and Stu stole
Cotton Weary’s coat and violated Maureen before
putting an end to her life. One of them left
the house wearing Cotton’s coat, and made sure
to leave in such a way that Sidney got a vague
glimpse, enough to identify the jacket and nothing
else. Perhaps Billy put the jacket over his head
as he loudly left, while Stu made a quieter escape
and hung low in a hole in the surrounding woods.
A woods burrow, if you will. Then Billy
planted the jacket in Cotton Weary’s car,
and that was more than enough to get Sidney
to testify against Cotton as an eye-witness.
But Billy and Stu could not just leave it at
that after their success. To learn how Billy
took his love of horror movies too far, why
he has facial hair in the poster despite him
never having that in the movie, he modeled his
killings after his favorite fictional characters,
and how he was inspired by a real life
criminal, stick around to the end of this video.
(Metal music)
Do you like scary movies? Good. Welcome to
Horror History. Billy Loomis was named after
two iconic horror movie characters whose movies
defined their generation. From the Boomers,
there’s Sam Loomis, Marion Crane’s boyfriend
in Psycho. Generation X had Dr. Samuel Loomis,
the psychiatrist of Michael Myers in
Halloween. Billy Loomis would carry the torch,
because Scream is a cornerstone for Generation Y.
The tradition would be taken one step further in
Billy’s eventual daughter, whose name is Samantha.
She ends up taking on the last name of her mother,
but if she had taken her father’s name, she would
be yet another Sam Loomis. Additionally, Billy
would steal elements of both Halloween and Psycho
for his own crime spree, which we’ll get to.
Billy is portrayed by Skeet Ulrich, who is clean
shaven for the entire film, despite what the movie
poster would have you believe, and also he wears
this shiny leather jacket for some reason. After
shooting Scream, Skeet played a part in the 1997
film As Good As It Gets, where his character,
Vincent, has facial hair. This is when they did
the promotional shots for Scream, so he couldn’t
shave and mess up the continuity in As Good As It
Gets. Ironically, for Skeet, Scream was as good as
it gets career-wise. Also, Photoshop did exist at
this time, but they decided not to use it I guess.
Screenwriter Kevin Williamson was partially
inspired by The Gainesville Ripper,
a criminal believed to have taken 8 victims
in the latter half of 1990. Other than the
fact that many of the victims were students,
there isn’t much resemblance to Billy Loomis,
but what is similar is the relationship
between the killers and the media. The
media was accused of exploiting Gainville
and creating a moral panic in order to
get more attention on their story. However, the
killer was doing it all for media attention. He
wanted to be a celebrity like Ted Bundy, even
breaking into song during his eventual trial.
– ♪ I recall the day I first saw you. ♪
– The media was feeding him with coverage,
and he was feeding them with content. The
Gainesville Ripper is not the only
criminal we can say this about,
but he is the one cited by the writer of Scream.
The Scream franchise has Gale Weathers,
a tabloid reporter who is unapologetic about
her motivation for catching the killer.
– Do you know what that
could do for my book sales?
– The aspect of the media exploiting the crimes
as entertainment also comes from the Gainesville
Ripper. During his trial, he claimed to have
multiple personality disorder and blamed his
crimes on one of the personalities, named Gemini.
This is a reference to The Gemini Killer from The
Exorcist III, the spirit of a serial killer
who possessed Father Karras.
“It was revealed that Rolling saw ″The Exorcist
III″ while in Gainesville, possibly hours before
he began his murder spree,” reported Ron Word from
AP News. So that’s where Williamson got the idea
for Billy Loomis to incorporate his love of horror
movie tropes into his plan, and he would do this
at nearly every level. But before I unpack that,
I’ve gotta talk about Billy’s secret girlfriend.
(mysterious music)
After the disposal of Maureen
Prescott went off without a hitch,
Sidney was experiencing post traumatic
stress which deterred her from getting
physical with her boyfriend. In
order to keep her on his hook,
he pretends to be patient and understanding
with her for nearly a year after the incident.
In order to satisfy his teenage libido,
he goes behind Sid’s back and gets with a
girl named Christina Carpenter, a fellow
high school student who ends up getting
pregnant with Billy’s kid. Christina
has her own boyfriend at the time,
who believed he was the father. Billy’s
affair is just like Hank and Maureen’s,
and his willingness to follow in his father’s
footsteps despite knowing the damage that it
can cause is a testament to his narcissism.
Billy would not be around to see the birth of
his daughter, because he and Stu had plans for the
anniversary of Maureen’s death in September 1996.
Their first target for that year would be Stu’s
ex-girlfriend Casey Becker, who is also a fan of
horror movies and familiar with horror tropes. In
order to make their story feel worthy of cinemas,
they take inspiration from popular slasher
villains at the time. Leatherface, Jason
Voorhees and Michael Myers were all known for
wearing a mask, so Billy and Stu did the same. In
particular, the events of Scream line up most with
Halloween, which is Casey’s favorite scary movie.
In Halloween, Michael Myers wears a randomly
selected white mask that he stole from a
Hardware Store, so Billy and Stu do the
same by getting these Father Death masks,
which can be purchased at any
five-and-dime store in the state.
They wait outside Casey’s house one night and
stumble upon her new boyfriend Steve Orth who is on his way over,
so they beat him up, tie him up, and hide him
away before making a call to Casey’s house.
(phone rings)
(impact)
(suspenseful music)
I'm guessing that Billy was the caller using a
voice changer device to speak with Casey,
not Stu. It’s Billy’s plan, and he’s definitely
the wittier of the two. I’m *not* sure whose
phone they might have used, maybe Steve Orth had
a cell phone that they stole after abducting him.
When Casey picks up, he flirts with her at first,
then strikes fear into her when he asks her name.
– Because I want to know who I’m looking at.
– She gets freaked out and starts hanging up on
him each time he calls, until he threatens to
gut her like a fish if she doesn’t stay on.
He watches the house from his hiding place
in the front while Stu waits out of sight
with Steve Orth closer to the back door.
I feel like the fact that there are two
Ghostfaces further supports the throughline
that they’re creating a horror movie. Most
of the slashers that inspired them had some
kind of supernatural element, and by having two
people in the same costume, they could give Casey
the impression that Ghostface is teleporting
between the front and back of the house. The
villain may be ringing the doorbell one moment,
and placing Steve on the back patio the next.
He challenges Casey to a game of horror movie
trivia, but the second question is a bit
misleading, causing Casey to get it wrong,
and Steve to be taken out as a result. The
third question again plays with the fact that she
doesn’t know there are two of them. He asks “what
door am I at” and when she refuses to answer, they
break in and search the house. In my estimation,
Stu is the one to stab his ex-girlfriend, just
based on her look of understanding, but not
surprise after she sees the killer unmasked.
Together, they hang her in a tree and gut her.
Later that night, Billy stops by Sidney’s house
and climbs through her window. She makes him hide
from her dad, who comes in and explains when he’ll
be leaving the next morning and where he’ll be
staying out of town over the weekend. This time
around, Billy is planning to frame Neil for the
murders, so overhearing this information is like
striking gold, and he remembers it for later.
– Close call!
– He tells Sidney about how he was
at home and saw The Exorcist on TV,
with all the good stuff censored for television,
and it made him think of their relationship,
which cooled off after Mrs. Prescott’s
death. It’s significant that he’s making
an analogy to The Exorcist, because remember,
The Gainesville Reaper lifted his story from a
movie in The Exorcist franchise as well, which
he supposedly watched right before going crazy.
He claims he’s not trying to rush into sleeping
together, and as he leaves, she asks if he’ll
settle for a PG-13 relationship. His words are
empty ones, but he really only has himself to
blame for Sidney’s hesitancy to get intimate in
the wake of her Mom’s funeral. He secretly does
want to go further with her, but only because it
fits into his sick fantasy of living out a horror
movie. Everyone knows losing your virginity
is a precursor to death in the horror genre.
Early the next morning, Billy and Stu capture
Mr. Prescott and hide him away in Stu’s house,
because his parents are out of town as well. They
park his car in the woods nearby and also steal
his cell phone, which they clone so that each
of them can make calls in order to frame him.
At school that day, Billy is interrogated by
police, just like all the Woodsboro High students,
and apparently they ask him if
he likes to hunt. After class,
they’re all sitting out in the quad eating
grapes and talking about what happened to Casey,
and Billy gets mad at Stu for lacking tact while
discussing how she was gutted. It looks like he’s
standing up for his squeamish girlfriend, but
he’s really just playing the part of innocence.
That evening, Billy knows Sidney is home alone,
having taken care of both of her parents,
and hides in her house while she’s
sleeping upstairs. He calls her,
using the cloned cell phone and after
asking about her favorite scary movie,
challenges her to find him, which eventually
leads to him busting out of her closet and
chasing her up to her room, where she barricades
herself. Despite going after her with a knife,
it is possible that he intended to let
her survive this encounter. He doesn’t
take his chance to cut her throat, and
he’s almost too clumsy during the chase.
Plus, he still wanted to take her virginity
before revealing himself as the killer in order
to further humiliate her, and he would have wanted
someone at some point to survive an encounter in
order to tell the tale and elevate the status of
Ghostface into a horror icon. For these reasons,
he ditches the costume near her front door
and goes around to climb into her window
in street clothes, pretending to be the
concerned boyfriend coming to the rescue.
– He’s gone. He’s gone. It’s alright.
— How would you know that? You haven’t checked
the house yet. To add further suspicion,
he drops his phone, and Sidney immediately makes
the connection -- it wasn’t very common for
a teenager to own a mobile phone at the time,
though it was maybe starting to get popular
based on Billy’s dialogue at the police station.
Also, why would the killer abandon his costume
before fleeing unless he was planning to go back
and be someone else? It doesn’t look too
good for Billy here, and he’s arrested,
but lucky for him, his dad was a lawyer, and he
begs the sheriff to call him as they book him.
Sheriff Burke does call Mr. Loomis,
so Billy is able to use his one phone
call at the police station to contact Stu,
who has the other clone of Neil Prescott’s phone
and the other voice changer, and instruct him to
call Sidney at the Riley household where
she’ll she’ll be staying later that night.
In the meantime, he glares at Sidney through the
interrogation room window, taking advantage of
the intimate small town police station to try to
make her feel bad for him and deflect suspicion.
After a short interrogation,
they move him to a holding cell,
and his dad encourages him to
keep his mouth shut for now.
– Wait for the lawyer Billy.
Hank is an entertainment lawyer, not a criminal
defense attorney, but I’m sure he has connections.
However, that ends up not really being necessary
because Stu’s Ghostface call to Sidney works
like a charm, nobody suspects there being 2
killers. The police also check his phone records,
which are clean, so he’s released the next
morning, and even has time to change his
clothes and style his hair… but apparently
not wash the fingerprint ink off of his hands?
Maybe he just decided to leave that in
order to make Sidney feel bad. He runs
into her in the halls and she’s still
pretty shaken up. He tries way too hard
to convince her of his innocence, despite her
confirmation that she no longer suspects him.
– I know, the cops said I scared
him away. It wasn’t me Sid.
– I know. He called me again
last night at Tatum’s house.
– See? It couldn’t have been
me, I was in jail, remember?
– He also chooses this moment as a really bad
time to try to guilt her into taking their
physical relationship beyond
PG-13, telling her that it’s
time to get over her mother’s death,
which understandably pisses her off.
– Stupid!
– The only reason he tried to put a little pressure
on her here is because they’re only a day away
from the 1-year anniversary of the Maureen
Prescott murder, so if he’s going to take
her v-card before taking her l-card… her life…
he’s gotta do it to in the next 40 hours or so.
After school, we see Stu leave with Sidney and
Tatum, but he does kind of go back towards the
school, so it’s basically 50/50 on which one
of them was the one to kill Principal Himbry,
and lean over him with the Ghostface mask
to watch the life leave his eyes. However,
I think it’s Billy, because of this detail: it’s
still daytime when Himbry loses his life. In fact,
the janitor is still here, so
it’s probably right after school,
too early to hang the body up at the
football field without getting caught.
This means he probably had to hide the body
in the office somewhere and go back later,
under the fall of night, to put it on display
under the goalposts, which by the way,
is another trait similar to Michael Myers, who
liked to use his deceased victims as decorations.
Stu was busy hosting his party that night,
and Billy doesn’t show up until later,
so I’m guessing that was him.
But before he would do that,
he would have to deal with a fellow student
who just knew that Billy was the killer.
(impact)
(rock music)
Billy and Stu touch base again at Bradley
Video store, which is packed with people
due to a run in the mass murder section, and
the fact that people just want to stock up
on entertainment because of the city-wide
curfew set to go into effect that evening.
Billy can be seen flirting with
two girls in the horror section,
another hint about his unfaithfulness to
Sidney. When he hears Randy Meeks’s yell out…
– EVERYBODY’S A SUSPECT!
– It spurs his curiosity and he goes over to
confront Randy just in time to
hear this spot on accusation.
– I’m telling you. The dad’s a red herring. It’s Billy.
(stinger)
– How do we know you’re not the killer?
– The two real killers gang
up on Randy and tease him,
and although Randy really
suspects Billy, he can’t prove it.
Shortly before curfew, someone in a Ghostface
mask stalks Sidney and Tatum in the convenience
store. This was probably Billy, because Stu
would likely be setting up for the party at
his house that evening. In any event,
it seems incredibly risky to just be
wearing the Ghostface mask around in public
when fear of Ghostface is pretty much the
talk of the town at this point thanks
to a special report by Gale Weathers.
We actually don’t see Billy’s face again until he
shows up at Stu’s party, but there is the question
of who killed Tatum, who lost her life to a high
quality garage door opener while trying to escape
a Ghostface who attacked her while getting drinks
in the garage. Some have suggested that this was
Billy, because of how he then approaches the front
door from the side as if he had run out the open
garage door and sprinted around the outside of
the house. It’s possible, but if that is the case,
he would have had to go the long way around the
house, counter-clockwise. If he was coming from
the garage, it would make more sense for
him to go the short way around, clockwise.
Plus, in order for him to lock Tatum into
the garage, then sneak in and off her,
he would have had to go through the party to get
to the door that connects the garage to
the house. Someone would have seen him.
So I think it’s Stu who briefly stepped
out of the party and killed Tatum,
while Billy was taking care
of Himbry back at the school.
Plus, Stu is the one to make this suggestion.
– Hey, Tate, grab another beer, would ya?
– [Zac] Stu offers his parents bedroom for
Sidney and Billy to talk and… whatever,
and Sidney surprisingly agrees,
so the two head upstairs,
with Billy gut punching his buddy on
the way for his lack of subtlety. Or
perhaps it’s a celebratory smack because
their plan is working so flawlessly.
Upstairs, Billy apologizes for his
behavior lately, but to his surprise,
she’s feeling contrite as well for shutting
him out as she wallowed in grief over the
past year. He compares her situation to Jody
Foster’s character in Silence of the Lambs,
having flashbacks of her dead father.
The following interaction explains
exactly how Billy sees their lives.
– But this is life. It isn’t a movie.
– Sure it is Sid. It’s all a movie.
It’s all one great big movie.
Only you can’t pick your genre.
– And with that, Sid cues him in that
she’s finally ready, and he plays the
part of the supportive boyfriend, making
sure she’s ready before they get into it.
As they get dressed, Sidney asks
about who he made his one phone
call to at the police station, and
he tells her that he called his Dad,
which puts her off slightly because she realizes
that Sheriff Burke was the one to call Mr. Loomis.
– [Sidney] I was just thinking if it were you it
would be a very clever way to throw me
off track. Using your one phone call to
call me so I wouldn’t think it was you.
– She seems to only be joking, but again,
he takes her accusation way too seriously,
making him look guiltier than he would have been.
– What do I have to do to prove
to you that I’m not a killer?
It wouldn’t take long to find out, because Stu,
now dressed as Ghostface comes up behind
Billy and butchers him with corn syrup
packets while his back is turned away from
Sid, giving the appearance of real blood.
From here, Billy plays dead while
Stu chases her though the house,
and he doesn’t emerge again until he hears Sidney
manage to lock Stu out. Pretending to be injured,
he falls down the stairs to sell the performance.
Strangely, she doesn’t notice there’s only one cut
on his shirt where he’s supposedly been slashed,
yet there are two trails of corn syrup. He takes
the gun, under the ruse that he’s going to use
it to protect her, so when Randy butts in and
claims Stu has gone mad, Billy reveals himself as
the killer, by quoting Norman Bates from Psycho.
– We all go a little mad sometimes!
– No, Billy!
– He also divulges how he used corn
syrup to fake his wounds, which he
learned from the prom scene in Carrie.
Like an actor giving a press interview,
he’s discussing all of his influences for
the movie that he and Stu are creating.
Speaking of whom, Stu appears
at the doorway to the kitchen
trapping Sidney in the foyer and
explains the nature of the game:
she dies no matter if she wins or loses. As
for the rules, Sidney has broken one of them.
– Now you're no longer a virgin.
Now you gotta die; those are the rules.
– The clock rolls past midnight and into
Saturday morning, the 1 year anniversary
of Maureen’s death, so they bring out their
surprise -- Sidney’s Dad. They place the voice
changer and phone back in Neil’s pocket
to make him look like the lone killer,
then they stab each other so they can
make themselves look like victims later.
Billy is a little overzealous when carving
Stu’s wounds, going a little too deep,
which starts a small argument between them. This
may be Billy’s psycho side taking over his body,
or it could be intentional. Now that
he has Sidney where he wants her,
he doesn’t really care if Stu survives or not.
Sidney tells them they’ve seen one too many
movies, which ties back to the inspiration
taken from the Gainesville Ripper, who many people
at the time believed was influenced by things he
had seen in media. It goes back to the age old
question: does bad behavior in movies cause bad
behavior in real life? This was a hot topic in the
mid-1990s. Scream was released the same year that
the Telecommunications Act of 1996 was signed
in… well… 1996. It standardized the v-chip,
a technology that allowed parents to
block programming based on the TV rating.
There is always a scapegoat for the
Karens and Mankarens of the world to
blame instead of just actually raising
your kids with proper values. Usually,
the blame goes towards whatever is popular at
the time. If Scream were made in the 1930s,
it would be radio. In the 60s it would
have been television. In the 80s,
rock and roll. In the 2000s video games and in
the 20s, social media. Now that I think about it,
there *was* a Scream movie in the 20s and
it’s villains *did* cite social media.
Is Sidney right? Has Billy Loomis
just seen one too many movies,
causing him to snap? There have been
a number of studies over the years,
resulting in an array of conclusions,
which was explained by Craig Anderson, PhD,
Director of the Center for the Study of Violence
at Iowa State University. He said, “media violence
is only one of many risk factors for later
aggressive and violent behavior. Furthermore,
extremely violent behavior never occurs when
there is only one risk factor present. Thus,
a healthy, well-adjusted person with few risk
factors is not going to become a school-shooter
just because they start playing a lot of violent
video games or watching a lot of violent movies.”
I guess Billy was kind of right, in
way, when he rebutted Sid’s claim.
– No Sid! Don’t you blame the movies! Movies
don’t create psychos. Movies
make psychos MORE! CREATIVE!
The psychos would would run into an issue,
however, when Stu discovers that the gun is
not where he left it, but instead in
the red right hand of Gale Weathers.
(impact)
(brooding music)
Billy Loomis now found himself to
be the one staring down the barrel,
which is concerning until he realizes she
has the safety on, giving him the confidence
to drop kick her out of the house, where
she’s knocked out against a support beam.
However, before he has the chance to finish
her off, he’s distracted by a bigger problem:
Sidney and her father have used the
distraction to escape from the kitchen.
It’s strange that Billy doesn’t just pull the
trigger on her once the shot is lined up. There’s
no reason he can’t shoot her and then still go
look for Sidney and her father. It’s very much
something that would only happen in the movies,
and as we know, it’s all one great big movie.
However, his vision goes red when
he realizes he’s no longer the lead
character. The tables are about to be
turned on him. Sidney calls the house
and claims she’s already contacted the
police, and Stu becomes useless when he
starts to get woozy from all of his cuts.
Once again, Billy has himself to blame.
He throws the phone at Stu and loses
his temper as he ransacks the house,
cutting up couch cushions
to get his rage out until he
gains enough composure to notice the
Halloween movie playing on the TV.
As I mentioned, Halloween is the template
for Scream, and as the main antagonist,
Billy is very aware of that. He sees
Laurie Strode hiding in the closet,
and realizes that Sidney must be doing the same.
However, before he can act, she strikes first,
by stabbing him with an umbrella, causing
him to drop the knife and the gun.
He’s saved when Stu uses the last of his
energy to bum rush her, but she’s able
to put him out of commission in the living room.
Randy comes back to, so Billy swiftly knocks him
back out with a punch to the face and pins down
Sidney, telling her to say hello to her mother.
She jabs a finger into his wound, causing him
to scream out and just before he can thrust his
knife down on her, a recently re-awakened
Gale Weathers shoots him in the chest.
– Guess I remembered the
safety that time, you bastard.
– This might have been enough to kill a normal
person, but I like to believe that Billy was
so motivated to make his life a movie, that
he held on just a little bit longer so that he
could have that one last scare moment that
he had seen in so many of his favorite films.
Sidney is ready for it though, and
delivers a headshot to put an end to
the terror that plagued Woodsboro
over the last year. But while
the threat of Billy Loomis may have
been gone, the horror would live on.
Early in this video, I described how Billy’s
name was inspired by a Halloween character,
whose name was inspired by a Psycho character.
This lineage was intentional. Billy was inspired
by horror movies of the past, but now that
he’d modeled his life after a horror movie,
he would go on to inspire
horror movies of the future.
And many people would be exposed to his story
when it was published in Gale Weathers’s book,
The Woodsboro Murders, later that year. The
book served as source material for a movie,
Stab, which came out the following year, in April
1997. Luke Wilson played the part of Billy Loomis,
and he was an even more obvious killer
than Skeet Ulrich was in Scream,
because in their world, Stab is a true crime
movie, so everyone already knows it’s him.
Around that same time, Billy’s daughter
Samantha Carpenter would be born. And also
around that time, his mother would go undercover
as a reporter named Deborah Salt, after gaining 60
pounds and getting a makeover, in order to try
to get revenge on Sidney for killing her son.
– You killed my son, and now I kill you,
I can’t think of anything more rational.
– But the problem is, you walked out on that
son, so I don’t really get why you care now.
I talked about several risk factors needing to
be present in order to make someone go psycho,
so I think we can safely add genetic
predisposition to the list for Billy.
Mrs. Loomis isn’t successful in getting revenge
on Sidney either -- she seems to have that same
cinematic reluctance to pull the trigger
when she probably should that her son does.
Mental illness continues to run down
the family to Samantha, who has to
take antipsychotics to calm her disturbing
visions of her father, which started when
she first discovered she was related in
December 2010, when she was 13 years old.
Stab became a huge franchise,
leading to many more little
freaks to try to follow in the footsteps of
Billy Loomis. At some point in the 2010s,
Sunrise Studios released a Stab Blu-Ray box set
which included a special documentary called Stab:
The True Story, where the real
Billy Loomis was featured.
No, you can’t actually watch that, but honestly,
you kind of just did. What can you can watch is
my comprehensive analysis on the entire Stab
franchise. Just click that video on the left.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell and
select all notifications and I will see you
in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(calm rock music)